let's bring in lara trump senior advisor
for the trump 2020 campaign laura good
morning to you
great to have you here this morning so
hogan gidley from your campaign has
already
said president trump 100 won the debate
last night tim murtagh from your
campaign
claims absolute total victory i'm sure
you'll say the same
but did the performance by the president
change any minds or sway any voters last
night
well i agree with tim and i agree with
the campaign assessment you just gave
there i thought the president did
an incredible job and look i i think the
criticism of him
from the first debate sandra was that
you know he was very strong against joe
biden we saw last night
that if you were looking for the
president to you know come back a little
bit be a little bit more measured we got
that version of donald trump last night
and he can do that he's always said
he can do that um but i thought he was
particularly strong
when he was actually talking about
things that mattered to the american
people when he was talking about the
economy reopening
our country getting kids back to school
the energy industry these are really
important things to americans so
look whether you're talking about the
tone of the entire debate or the
substance i think the president probably
did sway
voters his way last night we were very
proud of his performance
ari fleischer was on fox news just a
little bit ago
and had some advice for the president in
the days that followed this debate
on how to bring it home now watch this
is a race between an
outsider with results against a typical
politician
with no results who's moving left if the
president drives that simple theme home
in the next 11 days
a lot of good can happen for donald
trump he says the president has one
job left and it's simple drive home the
difference between an
outsider with results you just heard him
say and a typical politician with no
results
who keeps moving left what will we see
from the president as far as strategy
with 11 days left well you heard the
president say that last night he said
i'm not a politician
that's why i won in 2016. and he said i
i ran for president because of the
failed policies
of career politicians like you joe biden
i mean he literally said
that to uh to joe biden last night so i
i do think you're going to hear the
president echo that message he's been
saying it he continues to say
i have done more in 47 months than joe
biden has done
in 47 years uh but look it's it's also
about reminding people
what the accomplishments of this
president actually are so that's why
we're spread out sandra all across the
country our entire family
including the president vice president
we're out there reminding the american
people
what this president has been able to
deliver in record time
and why he is the only person that can
bring this economy back and get us to
those great heights that we saw not too
many months ago laura one of the biggest
moments of the night last night was when
the two
had this exchange over the coronavirus
and handling the pandemic watch
anyone who's responsible for that many
deaths should not remain as president of
the united states of america
we're in a situation where there are a
thousand deaths a day
now it will go away and as i say we're
rounding the turn we're rounding the
corner it's going away
johns hopkins university reports that
the seven day rolling average of new
cases in this country
is up 18 000 in just the last week laura
daly new deaths is up 9
you just heard the president make as
while joe biden painted a picture of
what he said could be a very dark winter
for this country
so did it help for the president to take
that approach considering
joe biden still is polling above the
president
on american voters and who they think is
best to handle this pandemic
well look at the onset of this we saw
that the predictions were that we could
see upwards
of two million deaths now one death is
too many our hearts go out to everyone
who's had to deal with this
but the president took on a novel virus
something we had
never seen before anywhere in the world
and so this was historic what this
president did not only
with testing with ventilators partnering
with the private sector
paycheck protection program now we are
on the precipice of a vaccine
in record time so when that happens i
think we're going to see a huge
change across the country and the
president has said that is probably
weeks away i think it's a terrible
message to send to the american people
that you heard from joe biden
that it would be a dark winter why would
we want to be so negative and dismal
that's very
very disturbing to hear you want a
president who's positive who's uplifting
who knows what's on the horizon as
president trump does with this vaccine
and i think we're going to see a big
change when that comes out quick
follow-up on that
we saw you as well as the president's
children walk into the debate hall
last night wearing masks you sat down
you wore them the whole time
was that a change in heart over wearing
the mask or was that because
the debate commission made that a rule
well that that's because they asked us
to wear the mask the whole time
again i continue to reiterate that the
first time around that was not
made you know perfectly clear to us we
walked in with them and we thought we
were okay to take them off when we sat
down
happy to keep them on if that was the
rule and that's what we did lara final
question on
women voters and we can put up on the
screen this is our new
fox news state polling on joe biden
and how he's polling versus the
president with suburban women
you can clearly see that joe biden is
running up the score among suburban
women
this concern the campaign and what are
you doing in the final days to try to
change some of those minds well look we
have continued to reach out to all
americans including women
i'll be on our women for trump bus this
week in my home state of north carolina
along with some great female surrogates
from the trump campaign
and we're excited to talk about the
president's track record what he has
done
for women all across america in the past
four years
what he plans to do not only to get the
economy back but to keep
everybody safe in america get schools
back open and those are really important
issues to women all across this country
i've only got a couple seconds left but
if we can put up on the screen the early
vote
count total everybody's talking about
this the the huge
number so far over 47 million have
casted their their ballots early
uh versus this point in 2016. uh it's
about 10 million more
is this something that the campaign is
concerned about is this a good sign
for joe biden and what do you how do you
analyze that
well we've been encouraging our voters
to get out and vote early if your state
offers early voting
go vote now get your vote locked in for
the president you look at states like
michigan
where we are far ahead sandra uh with
early vote and mail-in voting total
totals way ahead of where a republican
has ever been before so these are
actually looking
rather positive for president trump it
is a sign that
you know hopefully people are listening
to us and getting out and voting early
i hope we see those results in a big way
for president trump on november 3rd
lara trump appreciate you joining us
this morning thanks so much